foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
hello
banana
happy Friday
[Music]
one second one second one second
[Music]
[Music]
welcome everyone
it's time for sakiro
foreign
so first question we played the first
four hours of this game about four
months ago
should we just restart
we probably should
just to keep it like
streamlined
at least I think so
that was a long time ago I didn't even
realize how long ago it was
better
[Music]
yeah what language do you guys want this
in
I'm gonna I'm Gonna Keep it in English
actually
hold on
but also I figured out the camera
so you can see my face
it's pretty sus I'm not gonna lie
don't know how I feel about that you
guys don't want to read subtitles the
entire time do you
is that the really true
I know y'all are gonna say Japanese
that's what y'all are gonna say hold on
I'm figuring stuff out
okay we're good on that
we're in 4k excellent
excellent
we don't need to see your face
I mean I could turn the camera off if
you want
rude
hey man I can do that
how do I do this
hold on
[Music]
so if I'm on this
you guys see me right now probably not
actually yeah this is preview
and [ __ ] it I'll turn it off I don't
care
you don't get to see my face now
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
and now YouTube excellent now you guys
are too low
I'm just gonna keep it on
here
yeet
there you are
Vlad are you an [ __ ] what's going on
here man
we don't need to see your face I say
okay and you're like hooray
the hell
[Music]
all right hold on
[Music]
hey I'm fine with that
all right
yo I know I'll die more than twice I
promise you that
make the subtitles Japanese for extra
immersion
no
[ __ ] you sorry
subtitles on
there we go bring that up a bit actually
mm-hmm
yeah I mean hey blame Vlad all I needed
was one person to say we don't need to
see your face so I turned it off that's
all I needed man
so anyway thank you
all right I think we're good you guys
ready
currently on great owl fight and stuck
on his [ __ ] first phase
nah dude Al's easy
bro
all right let's go
I want to see face it's too bad
too bad
I'm very handsome too
you're missing out
Japan was consumed
the fires of War raged on
spreading deep into the mountains
[Applause]
hey
[Applause]
lucky
[Music]
[Music]
man needs tow Insurance
there's a member here he'd have us
it may be just life insurance
[Music]
[Music]
staged a bloody coup and rested control
of the land
dude the narrators they hire for these
games are so cool
[Music]
what's the matter stray Nothing Left to
Lose
who was owl fighting for well would you
look at the
fascinating
will you join me is he just here
on that day a young Cub was taken from
the battlefield yeah the voice acting's
insane and indeed went on to become a
master Shinobi yeah he must just be like
whoever paid him you're right forget the
Shinobi code
as your father my word is absolute I
don't know why their cutscenes in game
are also grainy like I know you guys are
seeing brain right now but I see it on
my screen too it's weird
defend him with your life same thing
with dark souls 3.
[Music]
you understand
[Music]
yes
I understand
Al is not that bad of a fight once you
figure him out he's hard for sure
very hard
some 20 years after eachine's coup the
ashina clan
was on the brink of collapse I feel like
the only people that say I prefer
Japanese are and the Shinobi known as
wolf had lost everything y'all watch
anime don't you
both the man who took him in the boy he
had sworn to protect
I've seen some anime too
I wouldn't say I'm an avid watcher of
anime though
I've watched the big the big
the big ones
except for like one piece that shit's
way too long
can I say something else or I'm Banning
you you're being weird
[Music]
Shinobi
open your eyes
what up Garrett for the sake
of your master
guys do you want it in Japanese I'll put
it in Japanese if you want I don't care
laughs
if anyone complains they can blame you
okay
[Music]
no
[Music]
I don't mind
Japanese please
yep bunnies okay
uh what do you want
vanish
I'm keeping it on English get over it
oop wrong button
ornamental letter
what's this way can I swim
excellent
nothing
all right do we want webcam on or not as
well I will turn it on again
and we'll ignore Vlad
I don't really show my face that much
anymore
and I won't I won't pull a dream on you
guys where I uh
pipe it up like crazy just to look like
you know
every person ever
on all right
put your webcam on sakiro's head
it'd be kind of funny actually hold on
I gotta turn on my light again
yeah
okay
hey I think I'm handsome too but
somebody said it bro
somebody's like we don't need your fish
get get your face out of here I'm like
all right bet
or actually is this gonna be in the way
now
wait hold on okay here I am hi no we're
good this is fine hello
hi
that's my face
I look like a normal normal dude
can't see chat now though
go over here
excellent
what's harder harder owl or Emma and
ishin oh
Emma and ishin
kid me way harder
I
that's me if you've never seen me before
I'm a normal human being
the Beard's gone I did shave I did yeah
I sometimes have a beard it's like
uh
it's like five o'clock shadow right now
I shaved yesterday
pretty normal
ruined
did you guys see the uh the face reveal
of do you guys know who dream is I'm
assuming you do
you know you dream
the the minecrafter guy he showed his
face for the first time
and like half the internet is like
debating on if he's like good looking or
not it's so weird
sorry I was getting my controller in the
right spot
yeah it was literally hard to avoid they
were talking about it on the news like
literally on CNN and [ __ ] like what the
f that's so weird
my beard goes past my nips
damn that's a good beard
they grilled him hard bro never turned
his face yeah he's like this
hey guys never been on camera before
it's really weird I I don't know I think
he was probably self-conscious he wanted
people to think he was cute which dude
he's a good looking guy
he's just like a normal good looking
dude right
it's such an odd debate of people like
dude this guy is [ __ ] disgusting
looking I'm like he's like the most
regular looking guy I've ever seen for
real
like just any guy I've ever seen it's
like okay yeah he's good looking
whatever
this is interesting
I thought I okay so dot I'm just gonna
call you dot because you have no name
and you're just a dot but uh
he he hyped it up like [ __ ] crazy and
he's he facetimed other YouTubers and
they're all like whoa oh my God like
without showing other people
and I'm like was that really your
reaction
when he saw this guy
you know what I mean
you're like whoa holy [ __ ] it's probably
because they've never seen him before
and probably different from what they
expected but
it's whatever
the dream will never fall off he is the
he's he's got the mine Crafters bro
can you imagine
to we might love your speed once
ashina Reservoir
[ __ ] all right
my bad like how the the music cuts out
as you go down
no normal looking dude has a jawline
like you do I have a jawline
kinda I don't have to go like this
[Music]
kill it off
Twitter was funny during that entire
thing though I will give it to that for
sure it was pretty funny
Twitter can be a funny place
sometimes
sometimes
and when's the last time I had my camera
on I have no idea
a while
how do I crouch is it just like Elden
ring yeah at the bottom of the well we
didn't shackle him restrain him nothing
I will say I think this voice this voice
acting is kind of weak
not only is he unarmed he's completely
lost his will to live Dark Souls 2.
coward that's probably why I turned it
off
foreign
it was it all had to do with dark souls
2.
that's why I turned it off forever well
for four months that wasn't that long
ago the Divine air is probably using the
light for his reading again probably but
imprisoning a mere child oh I did have
it on pigeon for the randomizer for a
minute
has his reasons
all right I am gonna do the thing where
I switch it
two Japanese
and if it's annoying we're gonna change
it back okay
how do I change it to Japanese or is it
too late
should I have done it at the beginning
game options no camera no sound
I think it's too late
I have to do it in the starting menu
so if I quit out right now
I'm gonna try it okay
I'm one of those guys like I've watched
I've watched Naruto
I've watched Attack on Titan
I've watched
the one where you write names in and
they die death note I've seen that but
they were all in English
so
it's not a flex I just I like ninjas I
think they're cool that's why I watch
Naruto
old language
it's literally language okay text
English voice
Japanese
[Music]
right
is the camera blurry no whatever okay we
continue now
watch berserk dude 50 of people say it's
awful
how did you see me you [ __ ] [ __ ] you
I turned to Japanese and they're like on
edge
that's racist
okay
I can't run here can I
there we go
wolves voice actors from Charles Red
Dead 2 I knew that I forgot that however
that's really cool
I love red dead too
great game
I kind of want like would you guys be
interested in a cyberpunk
stream because they redid it or they
didn't redo it but they added a lot of
updates that I would be interested in
playing again
then maybe red dead as well
that'd be fun
this guy goes no
love it
all right let's listen to this Japanese
like is it really that much better guys
[Music]
really that much better
oh come here
okay I'll keep it
just just by Wolf's voice right there
damn
[Music]
that was nice
although we don't get Charles
is pretty cool
foreign
[Music]
you guys are fine with reading all right
[Music]
I'm not gonna watch One Piece I'm not
gonna do it it's too much Naruto is too
much and it's like half of the episodes
I don't like boruto
I don't really like it I don't I don't
know why they made all the adult
versions of Naruto so [ __ ] weird I I
don't know I'm sure it gets better
but the beginning I'm like holy [ __ ]
I think I'll give it a try Blake
but I'm a big fan of that world the
Naruto Universe I really like ninjas and
stuff I think they're cool
foreign
yes I've watched Dragon Ball yes
I watched that in like tsunami Adult
Swim when I was a kid
we gotta go to the secret passage
mother
foreign
I give him the charm right
but then he tells me not to yeah
I feel like I'm watching an anime right
now it's kind of cool
I have not played a game in Japanese
before
because I'm looking in the bottom half
of the screen and reading
even though I know
keep it in your care yeah it makes the
game harder right no I'll keep it it's
already [ __ ] hard
you know the reason I stopped watching
boruto I think mainly had to do with
boruto being an [ __ ]
and
I just remember him saying something
like
to Naruto like you haven't gone through
[Music]
the [ __ ] I have and you're not even that
strong and I was like
[ __ ]
[ __ ] I just hated him and then I just
stopped watching it
don't know nothing
I won't get into that though
frenzy uh the most recent one I watched
was death note and I thought Death Note
was really cool
boom boom
oh I [ __ ] up guys
I wanted to deflect and I I'm already
dead man
do you have kids no I don't
even have a girlfriend dude I'm a loser
loser
loser
I already died
there we go that was better
foreign
gotta get used to the combat again but
it feels good
talk to the boy I already did we gotta
go to the secret passage
bring anything up here
I don't think I've ever gone up here
hello oh it's the guys gossiping
and now you're dead
not the hardest then what is your
hardest game oh that's where I came from
that's right
is there anything in here
no I think I come back here later and
there is stuff in there
I agree Garrett the hardest game ever
made is Superman 64. that is true
that is true
ow dog
[Music]
not a perfect deflect but we'll take it
I'll hug the wall I want to do this
I want to slurp up all the money
I wish I could do that in real life
well you wish you could just have an air
Vortex around your body and you can
slurp up everybody's money
that'd be great
what up D how are you
foreign
did I not get my flask
I thought I'd get that later
I thought he gave me the flask
yep I already got it
I gotta equip it
Spore I don't think I've ever played
Spore
disgusting
thank gourd
yeah
[Music]
drop oh the ring was my first firm
software game immediately went to skiro
after damn it was hard but rewarding a
beat agreed
I mean okay how many of you guys would
say sakiro's the hardest Souls game
I'm curious now
[Music]
you guys know what I had at the
beginning like right before I started
somebody in the chat goes
sekiro isn't a Souls game
shut up
Joy
Joey
bloodborne's pretty hard I'm not gonna
lie
we beat that in like five streams I
think
dealing no more money
dude Wolf's voice in Japanese is sick
beaconichiro kinichiro
oh you want me to beat him here this is
gonna be hard you actually can't beat
him
I'll do my best
you still lose
this reminds me of uh
gearman's boss fight in the garden
behind the the
you know what I'm talking about in
bloodborne
in the Hunter's dream
mikuyo
Dark Souls one is getting old
Garrett for sure I still think it's a
great game
I have like
sticky hair on my chest what the [ __ ]
not sticky but it's sharp like it hurts
the [ __ ] sorry
[Music]
his armor that he has on like on his on
his arms is so cool
you first tried Ludwig yeah because I
had two summons so I didn't even have
the full experience actually
[Music]
as some would say
you can't jump there I have to go to the
side [ __ ]
I'm forgetting my limitations currently
[Music]
okay
what you got bro
a whole lot of nothing
nerd
[Music]
back up
[ __ ]
oh he caught
oh
rip arm
I always miss jumping on his head
I gotta like pull in
that was actually pretty good
foreign
you guys said his voice acting's bad
no you're saying kuros is bad which I
can't like yeah
in second is true
scratch
I played ghost dushima when it came out
yeah
great game
very different from from this you know
all the endings
yeah
how many endings are there actually
well act yeah there's like different
versions of the last one and then
there's the shura right
um
you think
Alden ring is objectively better game
I think Elder Ring's the best open world
game ever I've always said that
um
this game has the best combat in any
game I've played
bloodborne might be the best game I've
ever played
like hands down best game ever
bloodborne
I just really enjoyed Dark Souls 3 a lot
dude look at his kneecaps on this man
look at this [ __ ] kneecap right here
boys
damn
I'm gonna do that a lot oh
no I love nothing
on me
sashes to me
Alden Ring versus Red Dead too they're
very different open world games
Sunday
but if you like being told where to go
and what to do
then read that too which I I don't like
being told what to do or where to go or
how to do stuff
which is why I like these games you know
some people like a marker on the screen
and they go to that thing you know
so yeah ask about your new left arm
foreign so it's uh she no big issue
take you I know coming here I dislike
how defensive you think sekiro's
defensive
I don't know about that one my guy
's in here early dude
foreign
foreign
Studio
okay
we have a new arm excellent excellent
remnants
should we can leave behind remnants uh
that's how people died right I think
yeah
who the hell is dying out here
most fluid Combat gameplay and All Souls
games welcome to skiro
hell yeah dude I think it has the best
combat for sure
let's get it
rappling hook
LT
yep
whoops
and as all from software games do
they present you the world in front of
you in such a beautiful way
on top of a cliff overlooking everything
as they do
in every game
beautiful
Elden ring is overrated
uh
um
okay
okie dokie
that's an opinion
good opinion
come on
you could slurp up the cash from a mile
away baby
okay
let's go over here
oh I have to lock on to do that shoot
I wanted to pull into Assassin's Creed
real quick
we have
[Music]
you guys think it's possible in today's
age
to just be like
to each their own
instead of being like Elden ring is
overrated
it's like okay
so you don't like it
yeah
what do you like
bloodborne's the better game it's like
okay
to each their own you like the style of
bloodborne
more than Eldon ring
I don't think that makes Elden ring
overrated
it just means you don't like it as much
as another game
you know now everyone's like opinion
opinion opinion opinion opinion
it's this weird I've started thinking a
little like deeper about that lately
so much opinion everywhere
oh we got the doggies
can I Parry a dog
yep
objectively better game you can Parry
the dogs objectively better
[Laughter]
excellent okay there's one Shinobi
prosthetic
or deflect the dogs
hmm
they're too suggestive
strange world we live in today isn't it
if I remember right and if I don't break
any sticks
I can get behind this guy
and [ __ ] it up and now I have to fight
him normally
oh man you went far on that reach
foreign
[Music]
okay
no no no no no no stop that
how do I use my gourd oh okay
[Music]
no
thank you
[Music]
I gotta remember to do this
it's gonna be a close one
foreign
prayer bead and a gourd seed
people are entitled to their wrong
opinions
sure sure
they are
that's true right yeah
of course they are
of course
but now it's like people get mad at each
other about opinions
you know
if they weren't so like I don't know
aggressive about it
would probably be pretty different
[Music]
yay oh I did not see you
no I thought I died
that's a good way to put it they're loud
about their opinions
okay I gotta get out of here I think
uh oh
what the heck there's a big dude up
there
I'ma hide
oh
oh yeah I forgot about the chickens
I literally
I literally died to a rooster
it's like dying it's like dying to uh
gun deer
it had to happen
death by black [ __ ]
excellent
does that count as a death
if I uh
didn't technically die
because I die twice
she gives us access to the dream world
right
gives us the Bell
I think
say nothing
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
got it
give me that Bell
thank you
and it's time to go
I gotta remember how to move
oh there you are
punching me
deserved
[Music]
okay I needed to get out of there
goodness gracious
I know I can deflect the hammer there
was just like you know another dude
there that was kind of distracting
you know what I mean
is there a way I can uh there's
something I can jump down over here I
think
yeah over here
right
I remember jumping here and I can grab
something let's just [ __ ] do it dude
why not
pickle Rick
what up dude
I died the Lord apologizes as he won't
be able to watch sekiro as he is
attempting to beat it as well
hate them a lot hear the scream and I
die so annoying so I apologize
never apologize pickle
whenever you're done you can come back
and watch it I appreciate the 20 Super
Chat that is very nice of you
W's in the chat for people pickle Rick
thank you man
I appreciate it thank you thank you
speed run
eat eat
[Music]
and and rooster
and there we go okay
wait do I have to get my gourd seeds to
Emma right I do I do
I do
uh let's let's go back here because she
should be here now I think
but thank you again pickle you're the
man dude
are you talking about whoa
oh
you mean the kite guys yeah
that'll be fun
you killed
you guys you don't like this voice
acting
um
I like it
foreign
she's like a fire keeper assists Us in
any way that she can interesting
I think Elden ring is better than Sakira
no to each you know like they offer
different things I don't think one's
better than the other
if I want to play an open world game I'm
going to play elderly if I want to play
a game with excellent rhythmatic combat
I'm gonna play this game
you know
hi
hi
I'm not ringing the demon Bell
we're just trying to play the game
yeah I grabbed the shuriken thingy
you want to watch the Mario movie
it looks pretty good
do you guys see the trailer it looks it
looks good
which is surprising
hmm
very cute
foreign
foreign
that's the questions we should be asking
which game has the best
Maiden
after playing Dark Souls 3 Guys
fire keeper in Dark Souls 3 is my pick
she's awesome
that's my pick dude
Melanie uses us
Ronnie uses us
I don't you know like Emma's okay
Dark Souls 2 is pretty cool too that's
the only thing I like about Dark Souls 2
is majula the rest of it man
the doll pretty close in bloodborne the
doll is pretty cool
I do like the doll
I I think it's dark souls 3 fire keeper
for me
personally
to each their own
interesting how that works
uh I'm not gonna give him the Bell yet
we need to go elsewhere first
so can I do this yet no I need four
prayer beads Scrabble two
yeah here right yeah
we gotta fight a troll bro
this fight can go really well and
nothing will go bad
and that's it right
this fight won't possibly cuck me
all right guys
money money money
this fight won't possibly tuck me bro
what is with these Bots today
[Music]
if you clicked on the bot you're an
idiot just saying
foreign
could not have gone better just as I
said
wow
just as I said
could not have gone better
akiri counter will be amazing later
that's honestly our first order of
business is getting makiri counter
obviously
oh that's a balloon full of wealth
I Love Balloons full of wealth
pick me up
oralu on meth
I kind of
I agree with that
John Cena
thank you
Lord seed why is my game lagging stop
bro
also
um
I have the game on Max settings because
I have I actually have a pretty good
graphics card
like a really good graphics card
so this
this is looking pretty damn good
for now we are going to sneaky sneak
um
okay
I gotta kill the guy the Bell guy
actually it doesn't matter I'm playing
this on PC
you know what I'm surprised they didn't
do
you imagine if there was like a few
swords in Alden ring
oops can you imagine that if there were
a few swords in Elden ring
that had a
like able to the option to deflect like
you can in this game
I'm actually very surprised that they
didn't do that I'm very surprised
where's this nerd okay
sir I need you dad like right now yeah
that's why
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
okay
don't have mercury counter I need to
remember this
okay bad
foreign
go again
I thought I died
[Music]
[Music]
what
not good Fellas
not good
I gotta get used to it
I'm on a controller
uh they didn't because eldering was in
production when Sakura came out Elder
ring is based off Dark Souls 3 assets
and Technology yeah I mean you're saying
that they couldn't have put a weapon in
they totally could have
with similar mechanics
totally Coulda did
but maybe maybe you know maybe they
tried it and it didn't work
okay let's try that again
because that was pretty
[ __ ] awful by me
yeah they they could do it still
come
sir
[Music]
you're annoying and fat
[Music]
that's right I told him I told him
what's up
why did they only defend when this guy's
around
[Music]
[Music]
fair enough
[Music]
no
this is so annoying
and of course the other guy's only
defending
as he attacks me excellent
oh my God
I'm going to this
foreign
[Music]
I think I'm just bad
rest
what is your overpowered weapon now
um skill
I want to kill this guy though
because he gives me a gourd I think
right
you you dead now get out of here
here
dude
you should level up you should level up
your face
okay let me know when you do that
let me know I'll be really excited to
see it
I'm dead
we're gonna get through this
gonna be fine
everything's gonna be just fine
[Music]
come come
[Music]
[Music]
this area is very frustrating
[Music]
I need Mercury catheter man
[Music]
[Music]
just kill him smile
I want him dead
okay okay let's do this properly
and slowly
okay watch
just wait
[ __ ] you
indeed Estus gourd
isn't there a fistful of Ash in another
game
in the from software series Fistful of
Ash why do I know that
okay here we go
here we go this is already way better
haven't alerted anybody
isn't there a dude in the corner over
here being a weirdo
yep
you're dead
and here we go
[Music]
you can't kick me that's illegal
that all of that was illegal you can't
do that
not fair
okay
dude his timing is so weird I don't know
what it is about this guy in particular
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
stop it
bro
[Music]
I mean there's one
foreign
one of the few games that you can pause
by the way guys if you didn't know
take the damn pellet
slowly heals me
foreign
[Music]
you can deflect those
[Music]
where did that ink came out of nowhere
just did it man
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
yes okay wow
my God
that guy is a [ __ ]
oh it gives me a prayer bead you can
pause an Elden ring
can you pause an Elden ring you serious
huh
no you can't
you can pause but it doesn't actually
pause the game
what are you talking about
no you got guys you know what I'm saying
you know what I mean like not going to
the map and going to explanations to
like cheese it or whatever but to just
pause like press
pause
shut up
shut up
what are you doing here
foreign
defensive guys
you pause Eldon ring and it pauses
I swear to God you can't
I don't think you do
shut up
foreign
I have 500 hours I'm like can you
because all of you are like no you can
not all of you some of you
okay I'm three out of four on prayer
beads we need one more
okay
let's keep going
I wonder if this could this inspired
Reichard
is this here
I don't have McCurry counter yet
big snake
how do you deflect the snake
I'ma poke it in the face
right in the eye
then all of a sudden it's bloodborne
look at my body
I'm scared I'm scared I'm scared
it's actually a God in Japanese
mythology that's pretty cool
gotchin sugar gotcha sugar
oh I didn't rest rig
I have to remember to hit the rest
button
the rest option
that poor snake he was gonna eat me dude
what would you rather I just die
come on dude
I can't really do anything right now
how's uh this guy's
I forget his name what's this guy's name
I am
yashitaki oniwa is he gonna sound cool
in Japanese
this is such a cool area
pretty cool
ow
[Music]
sir I don't even know if you're
attacking or not
there you go do more of that
wrong side my guy
[Music]
what did I get hit what okay
okay it's the tree Sentinel exactly
I think I prefer the English version of
this
I'm not gonna lie
okay I'm dead
I forgot the switch
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yo this music's really good there we go
I like how the the horse shoves me off
there that's pretty cool
GG
mechanical Barrel mechanical metal
Barrel that can be given to the sculptor
to enable
it appears to have been made reinforced
core to make a Shinobi's fangs even
sharper what is that
that's pretty cool
I remember ever using that I'm not big
on Shinobi tools I just like deflecting
it's kind of how I play the game
zero deaths
actually I died a couple times
Pro Gamer that'll be the title for
tomorrow guys Pro Gamer absolutely
annihilates Sakura
there we go
that increases our attack power a bit
um
wait did it what did I just do I already
did that okay enhanced physical
attributes no
let's rest and then we'll go back
to the tempo
[Music]
okay I gotta get used to the menus again
what is that instantly explains dude I
read the the description Derpy burp
never mind why am I talking to a Derpy
burp
I wasn't I'm not aware of what
specifically
um
now you guys can see how I look at you
when you're being weird
foreign
no
don't know Yuna
whatever I died
Chad are you horny
do you know
so the Divine dragon's heritage
allows
the blood allows you to resurrect
again
she sounds better in Japanese
I'm just trying to give her a gourd see
there we go I need to give her my seed
chat
you say that it's probably this Bell
gotta offer to the sculptor we already
talked about that okay
I will offer it to you sir
[Music]
foreign
secrets of Shinobi Arts
such moves should never be practiced by
a samurai
um
foreign
Future Wolf
I mean
I wouldn't say so
well that is one of the endings
I don't think it's him
hi Teflon English
foreign
there is a vicious cycle just like in
all of these games that you can become
the sculptor yes
you guys want a foot cam instead of a
face cam
foreign
loaded shuriken
created
that's what we got
um
foreign
that's right I have to equip it
this one should I go here yet
probably not
[ __ ] it
militarily
foreign
this game's very
it's a good word for it it's very
soothing
when you're not in combat obviously
that's where I'm going right here out of
the state
foreign
in cutscenes three years ago
oh that was fast
I thought it'd fade me in or something
more pellet boys excellent
hope your idol found
okay so now I can acquire skills
is this Mercury counter boom acquired
I don't care about Whirlwind slash
running slides pretty cool I could save
we're gonna get all of them anyway it
doesn't matter let's get that
um
should be good
what up plush
I think ogre is meant to be a block to
encourage people to go to the estate
yeah I think you can like out level this
place pretty pretty quick if you don't
come here I think when I am right now
you
more Ash
ton
asking me
that's a short scooter
what year is it emo yeah
foreign
I've made some shorts
that's lore you want us to tell you or
you want to take it by yourself
this game
I'm playing it for stream
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
no doggies
I love that you can deflect the dogs man
that is great
there stop it
[Music]
wait I can make your counter now
I forgot
why do you guys keep telling me to jump
in the water
why
there's a fishy
[ __ ] it
got him
thank you
sir
you're bad at your job bad at your job
you're rushing this one as you did the
others what are you talking about what
okay
can we swim in Elden ring oh yeah
oh sorry
I wanna hear what he says
wait
this reminds me of like orphan of cause
area
foreign
[Music]
okay
Divine grass
here's all ailments
I'm over leveled
um
sorry guys
sorry fellas
do I want sake
you guys ever had sake like in real life
[Music]
it's pretty hardcore
you know
stop with the ashes of war the hell are
you guys talking about
[Music]
Fair
very fair I like that that felt good
[ __ ] you
fair and balanced
kick dirt my face
I don't think I've ever seen that before
wow okay
neat
yeah it is pretty good
it's pretty uh I guess it depends
did I not rest
wait they're all going to come back if I
rest break
we'll be fine I don't need it yet
fast span
why are there so many sex bots on
YouTube like what the [ __ ] is up with
that
excellent
someone back here right yep
come on out
I see you
[ __ ] you
YouTube will become like twitch
I couldn't disagree with that more
which is gonna die to YouTube
in the next five years or so I'd say
is this the last soulsborne game
um I don't know we'll see
[Music]
we have any other ones to play
we could finish Demon Souls
that's something
I don't even I don't think Jeff knows
what twitch is
Jeff Bezos
I'm just rolling through people here
dude give me all that skill
give me that XP baby
[Music]
yeah twitch doesn't earn them any money
uh
like at all
I I mean I really doubt Jeff I'm sure
Jeff Bezos knows about twitch but he
doesn't do anything with it at all
like he doesn't give a [ __ ] what happens
to it if it doesn't make them money
which it doesn't then he'll get rid of
it
eventually
you just will
I don't think anything's over there
they made a tub category
uh
yeah I will
never understand that one
who else is here oh he's up on the hill
I need this
plane barrel
ready went in there is there anything
open here
oh my God
cell twitch to Elon
I think that's what will happen they'll
they'll sell
I think YouTube will buy it YouTube will
buy it that's my theory
eventually
that's what I was thinking dude
oh no
[ __ ] scroll
you
[ __ ] you up
son
more more
I love Death Scenes dude they're so
weird
oh
yeah we're burning this Temple next
leave it
there's something good in there right
foreign
how can actors do death accurately
I don't know based on depictions of
actual people dying I guess
but it's definitely not like
I don't think
I don't know I don't I've never seen
that
it could be like that I doubt it
sugar
I always call it Gohan sugar
hello
oh this is where I killed everybody
excellent
I yeah I feel like I'm playing an anime
right now
just because you guys made me switch to
the uh
the Japanese text or voice acting
[Music]
oh there's just a bunch of roosters out
here bro
foreign
that's how I'm gonna go out
yes I love this big black [ __ ]
you want a demon souls for PC
well that's not the deal we got sir
sorry to say
is there more over here
why is the music so sad
probably because like everyone's dying
actually
sugar
do you know that there's a lock on Fiji
you're not using the lock on feature do
you know that there's a lock-on feature
no I didn't know that thanks for letting
me know
[ __ ] up bro
how the [ __ ] do villagers have killer
chickens
that's a great question why are they
trying to kill me what am I doing to
them actually I attacked them never mind
I don't know
I can't get back up there
damn all right
we gotta go this way now
eat
we go this way what up Nick
[Music]
I love the grappling hook in this game
as well I don't think I've said that
it's excellent
oh eavesdrops
huh
you're dead
what the oh my God
out of nowhere
these long ax things
there we go
all right we're fine
Shadows die twice [ __ ]
this came out of nowhere man
foreign
I mean we got torrent so
yeah I'm using the the camera today Trey
long time no see
very rare day with the camera
can I see who's in there no
no
we don't know
foreign
oh God here we go
oh Shield boys
[Music]
anything but the shield boys I'm not
even gonna fight them they suck
what
I don't think okay we're good we're good
walk away
walk away
walk away
come on
I know
gotcha
foreign
pain
[Music]
oh I was gonna make here you
foreign
all these other people whoops
dude
[Music]
their attacks are so incredibly slow
thank you
I'm dead guys
[Music]
I'm getting ganked dude
uh a tactical Retreat may be the uh best
option here
for sure
[Music]
foreign
a bot while I'm playing
here we go
the gank fights in this are kind of hard
it's hard to
I guess they want you to sneak around
whereas I'm just like running full blast
right through it
if you die in the dream you wake up
outside the dream
interesting
what up Miro
hmm
means I'm Italian
oh yeah Dragon rotted that's right
Essence sculptor somewhere a pained
cough rings out continuously the man who
cops zealously sculpts statues of Buddha
to avoid being consumed by the building
flames
owning this item reduces one's chance of
receiving unseen Aid wrought Essence
timid made
coughing Arduino said the same thing
somewhere as he's right there
somewhere guys okay I have to pee really
bad
BRB
look we back
no I was not gonna take you with me
to pee
obviously
okay
no
Shinto
Dory
um
only on only fans
foreign
prosthetic okay
upgrade prosthetic tool
is that what I just did
holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
I don't know if I've ever done that
before
lame vent
loaded ax
now I own
how much do you think my only fan should
cost
um
sounds good Derpy
Book of Secrets okay we already know
that
is
foreign
gross man
loaded shuriken loaded ax flame vent and
now I can Circle through them huh
okay that's [ __ ] gnarly
uh can I just travel back do I have any
gourd seeds for you oh hi dudes
they're talking about the dragon rot and
how it affects the world okay got it
Ma
you know how Reddit works
not really
is there stuff like that on Reddit
what
rest
and then
gravel so I can go back here
perfect
35 bucks it seems expensive
if it's dirty it's on Reddit dude what
the [ __ ] is Reddit
just seems crazy
oh
God damn just let me go
I just want to go up the hill man
that's it
[Music]
mm-hmm
nice
nice that's [ __ ] dope
Reddit moderation is
rubbish
sounds like you got in trouble in your
butt hurt
I'm not gonna lie
let me see this wait
dude it won't let me
get off the ledge
there we go
he's trying to clear people out
[Music]
Mercury counter baby
that's a sweep got it
that's a sweep
what happened did the other guy hit me
foreign
I am justifiably butt hurt
sounds like you're just butt hurt
s
users same users have read it and
through the power of community well but
I'll just pay you here and you can send
me the pics later okay Wing
[Laughter]
man I appreciate that I don't know what
currency that is but I appreciate it's
about nine bucks so thank you very much
I appreciate that thank you thank you
oh I can't hang up here
but thank you very much
I'll uh yeah just join the Discord
we'll see what we can do there
everybody should join the Discord by the
way
I need more people talking in there
Reddit can actually be fun though you
just have to step away from toxic
communities
how's the Alden ring community
nowadays
let's get that
yeah I do not go on Reddit at all
not a fan
okay let's actually clear [ __ ] out
this guy somehow lived through all of
that
there we go
hey fear how you doing
[Music]
and
I'm just trying to heal one time
excellent thank you Bonk
it's a little bit too slow
oh
I like the Prosthetics they're fun I
need to use them more
foreign
[Music]
I can use that I think I can upgrade my
attack power now because that's four
prayer beads
I have to go for now my tune in later
again have fun see you Tim
have a good one sir
need uh work to stop getting the lay of
these streams I do stream during work
hours don't I
I do do that
enhanced physical attributes HP and
posture excellent
perfect
um have three
what does this do suppress presence
requires latency removing one's presence
is part of what defines a Shinobi
reduces an enemy's ability to perceive
those who are in stealth meh
kind of mid No Cap grappling hook attack
chasing slice
get this mid-air deflection
know the eyes to press sound
I'm gonna save these points because I
don't really want this stuff
did I say doo doo LOL
British [ __ ]
[Music]
iframes hi friends
[Music]
oh hello sir I did not see you
well irrelevant
[Music]
okay dude there are a lot of guys here
damn
okay just a lot of Arrow boys
thing I strafed around that guy
sir
dude this guy shows that you can die to
anything in this game
out of nowhere with
coming at me hard in the paint
oh God here we go
[Music]
I like the little hop stuff he does
okay I wanted to fire blast you
boy
look at that ass bro
bow with the Hops
I love it
I keep not uh
pairing
there we go
see that is sick
that was actually [ __ ] cool
[Music]
could be okay
foreign
scratch all that
should be okay he says
son of a [ __ ]
good thing Shadows died twice
Fistful of Ash
did I start new game plus an eldering or
wait for DLC series question
uh play New Game Plus absolutely
well
that's a tricky one
you would want a character oh wow
you would want one of your characters to
be not New Game Plus so you get whatever
the DLC difficulty level is you know
what I'm saying
so you could start a new character
and level that
to like the end of the game and then not
touch it
or you can just not touch it make a new
character a new gameplay do new do a new
game that way you know what I'm saying
so it doesn't mess with your difficulty
when DLC does come out hopefully that
makes sense
[Music]
uh Fistful of ash tray get your head out
of the gutter my guy
foreign
exactly Garrett
I
Oh Come you
how are you
hidden temple key
s
it's beautiful
[Music]
welcome you
know
run over
come you
know
that was a good deaths too
our dad died
daddy dead
adoptive dad oh [ __ ]
are you kidding me I can't get out I
literally can't leave okay
stick dude that's great
I I love that I I I was trying to
Grapple up and there was nothing to
Grapple onto man
damn that [ __ ] was brutal that just
killed me immediately what the [ __ ]
I'm sprinting
[ __ ] it dude
oh God
leave it to me to do something dumb like
that man
hello can I grapple
it's happening right now
seems safe
[Applause]
I feel like uh that might be a potential
video idea guys as to
I would title the video
you should probably play Elden ring
again dot dot dot and then talk about
like I think a lot of people don't know
that you should probably make sure that
your character isn't like new game plus
seven when DLC comes out
because I think a lot of new players
don't know how DLC Works in these games
there we go
where they're integrated into the game
oh my God let me jump please
thank you
oh I gotta talk to dad again
dad's dead
yeah I because I mean think about how
many uh new players there are to these
games
who
might leave a bad taste in their mouth
if they go into like DLC in their new
game plus seven character
and it's already like absurdly harder
than they really want it to be with the
DLC experience
but then again I don't know that could
be an interesting video
hey Rich now I played this game when it
came out I played it a good amount
but I wanted to play it on stream here
so I kind of know what's going on
I got the the grasp even though I'm
still apparently ass
weirdly
I can jump here
Chad I'm a little scared of lady
butterfly like I'm not gonna cap with
you right now
I go in here huh
okay
[Music]
New Game Plus makes the game harder
not by a lot but it does
imagine ease dropping this close
we got the somber 3 Trump no problem
welcome beautiful
foreign
[Music]
it just won't be the uh default
experience Mabel
that's all I'm saying
like they did in their first playthrough
first playthroughs of souls games are
sacred
foreign
s are usually integrated into the game
so that kind of depends
oh my God
leave me alone for two seconds
[Music]
okay you're dead
thank you
I'll take the hit on that one
nice
music go hard
um no they're not necessarily harder so
like ring city was in game so that makes
sense for it to be the hardest part of
the game or the hardest
hardest
part of your playthrough first
playthrough
um with ashes of ariandel which was the
first DLC for Dark Souls 3.
um it was like in the middle of the game
that you could access it halfway through
a playthrough you could access it
yeah it's the highest highest scaling
part thank you
ninja movement
foreign
so that's that's kind of what I mean
which I'm gonna go ahead and say that
Elden ring will do something similar
but perhaps not
[Music]
I think it would just be a nice video to
be like you should probably go make
another character if you don't have one
that isn't New Game Plus
so that you don't have to like you know
what I mean
you don't have to go like do it again
[Music]
uh
uh I actually need to go back
yeah we're gonna come back here
I need to go get something from
the outside of the wall
or the gate yeah
and see if you picked up Miss Raven
I don't think I did
into this game Josh yeah the gameplay is
really fun
wow that hurt
I don't know about monkey demons
there is a guardian ape in this game
though
wow
oh this is gonna sound sick
I don't know man I'd be down for new
game plus seven DLC for the first time
probably introduced more cheap [ __ ]
like poker Melania so you're gonna have
to use cheese stuff
better to be prepared uh well okay so
you're not getting what I'm saying it's
it's about the difficulty scaling so new
game plus seven like you're on for the
first time is totally scaled so you
could have like a very strong character
at the end of your first playthrough
not in any type of new game
so you're you haven't gone new game you
said No at the end or whatever and then
you go do the DLC you're already
probably overpowered or a DLC that'll
come out they might do it differently
that's the thing because it's been so
long
um I don't remember like how it went
when I played like Dark Souls 3 and DLC
came out
I remember
it was hard to find because they kind of
hide it you have to go find it
um
so you have to you know like how we
entered in Ash's variantale you have to
go talk to Gail in the church that's
about halfway through the game now you
can always
travel anywhere you want so it's
probably not going to be that big of a
deal but just like scaling wise like
what do you want the default difficulty
to be totally depends on you like if you
want to do it new game plus seven I go
for it but if you want that like what is
the default difficulty because I think
Melania default compared to Melania new
game plus one and two is ridiculously
different to me like the damage output
stuff like that is is very different I
haven't even done new game plus seven I
I like to delete characters and make new
ones anyway so that's all I'm saying
is if you want that like default
difficulty experience
then
you probably want a character that's not
new game plus and then you can go do the
DLC again
on your new game plus seven character so
like some people are I'm saying that
some people might be disappointed in the
fact like oh I only have one character
and new game plus seven I wonder what
these bosses are like in a normal
uh run through a default no new game
plus type of uh difficulty that's what
I'm saying
I love him already
what is your name yeah
I love this guy dude
Soldier
[Music]
this is yes
[Music]
[Music]
where's the merchant silly
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I want to learn Japanese
[Music]
I want to learn Japanese and go to Japan
outside and right okay thank you isn't
there a gourd seed at the top of this
area
foreign
rat description I already killed the rat
so we should be good
I think that's how it works you
[Music]
there's a bead upstairs right oh okay I
killed the rat
foreign
I kind of agree with you Garrett
[Music]
the more I
like her fight
however I think her waterfowl is
cheese
I'm always gonna think that there are
ways around it
which we know now
but when that [ __ ] was first out it was
ridiculous
you know what I'm saying
I think that waterfowl dance from
Melania will always be [ __ ] cheese
but the more I've played it the more I'm
like this fight is pretty cool I like
the fight
it's just annoying
learning Japanese is fun took two
Japanese language classes high school
for my experience is fun
yeah
I'll give it a try
there we go
I don't I don't know guys like I don't
mind her healing thing I really don't
I don't I think that that's fine
I think her being able to heal through a
shield is kind of dumb
it's almost like it should be like
bloodborne for her right like she has to
land a hit and get blood out you know
for it to work something like that but
I don't know
okay you said it was out into the left
ah right here
hello sir
cool
anyone who says sakiro isn't a Souls
game is not a soul still
I just could not disagree with you more
you just don't know what you're [ __ ]
talking about purchase
you said this guy is a gourd seed
dragon's droplet
oh yeah
I gotta have a k for that [ __ ] okay wait
I have some poppy boys
some poppy boys
inventory
I can use one at a time
is this what I want no this like gives
me more [ __ ]
coin purses is what I want that was dumb
[ __ ] I need like a few more points
isn't there a dude here sometimes
some coins I'll come well it's kind of
annoying to come back to this let me go
over here kill some people
can I go up here
oh
where did Miyazaki say it's not a Souls
game
out of curiosity
and I don't I don't think you get what
we mean when we say Souls game
where like yeah obviously
it's still a part of the like genre
still a part of the sea like not a part
of the series but a part of the genre
that for some reason when you say Souls
game pisses people off oh I can just go
through here can I
yep I see
one purse oh
okay
they're giving me the pellets
eat you're what I'm thinking of oh my
bad
lots of [ __ ] Ash dude
[ __ ]
three more
let me up
let me up bro okay
we're good run away
run away
[Music]
why am I talking to you okay
I need to go over here
how about souls like
I mean yeah I just
makes everything a lot easier you know
what we're saying when we say Souls game
Souls Dark Souls one two three Demon
Souls bloodborne sakiro Elden ring it
you know what we're saying and it's when
people go like it's not a Souls game got
up [ __ ] dude just calm down it's like
people have to have this uh
it just doesn't matter
it just doesn't matter
okay we got a gourd seed we'll go back
to Emma we could go up here and fight
the bull as well I think we can beat the
bull
without going back yet so let's go do
that
[Music]
Speed Run tactics
yeah what are we supposed to call it
Soul stalls borny row
or something
now
please kill the other guys Mr Bull
this is not how I wanted this to go
[Music]
wait what are we what are we doing here
man
there we go
damn
foreign
foreign
foreign
rip the bowl
[Music]
no it's not my first playthrough
I played it when it came out
[Music]
hello lady
where are we going before oh we're gonna
go fight uh
lady butterfly in that area over there
right
let me rest
I think he meant that sakiro doesn't
have the classic leveling up build
variety
that's why he called it a non-souls game
well yeah obviously like
that's not the point it Jesus Christ
it's not the point man I think that's
what people are kind of missing
absolutely
and then these ascending and descending
carps are really good
hey metal how are you
the argument the argument's the fun part
it's not I dude does people argue to
argue nowadays it's just so [ __ ]
annoying
it like I I have to have a problem with
something you know I don't
it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter
it really doesn't
okay should we go to
we gotta go to Emma to get the gourd
seed that's right
we'll do that first
it'll babe five
[Music]
this feels Daft like you said you
understand what people mean when they
say it
me
I'm confused now this makes me angry for
some reason the term we should coin
everything is Souls like not Souls born
bloodborne Falls the same archetype of
Souls
mm-hmm
I get a lot of depression and low energy
so I can only argue to a certain point
before I'm drained
honestly same man or I I agree with that
for sure
I'm up earlier to go get my shot rocked
I'm so stoked what is what is shot
rocked
to go get your [ __ ] rocked
foreign
I find it like people are just purposely
being annoying when they're like it's
not a Souls game when you call it a
Souls game whatever
it's just [ __ ] annoying conversation
that doesn't even need to happen They're
just causing problems for no reason
foreign
I think it's bait I can't tell but he's
he's going pretty descriptive on it so
okay
we got our gourd seed
let's go back to the dream lady
butterfly makes me very nervous
honestly the boss fight before lady
butterfly makes me nervous because that
[ __ ] can be annoying as hell
let's do it anyway
why not dude
[Music]
Thane sakiro is soulsborne just cause
it's a from software game is like saying
a first person shooter because
Activision published it
it's not it's not what we're [ __ ]
saying dude
[Music]
It's gotta be bait I'm over it
no way that you're this like
wow excellent
I love doing this again
[Music]
hurricanes my friend
I'm a deflecting [ __ ] I love deflecting
no I didn't rest I fell
and that hurt I guess
huh
onushi
no fight buddy we got this
yeah yeah
that guy's voice acting is uh
[Music]
okay
I'd say
okay let me get rid of this guy
[Music]
this guy
up our boys dead
now
how do I dodge that it's weird
ow
okay
we are struggling with the dodging on
this guy
[Music]
y'all saw what I saw right oh God
[Music]
oh this sucks
[Music]
where did this guy come from
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this sucks
another guy in a fight just makes
everything so much harder
especially when it kicks dirt in your
face
[Music]
okay
so annoying and I can't like get them
bro I just can't get them
how did he die I don't think I hit him
[Music]
good
we got something
never mind
[Music]
tree is not helping me right now
nice
nice dude
popped off a little bit
we will take that
popped off a little bit
yes sir oh he came from over here
these guys that have no hearing ability
can't tell what's going on
oh what's going on bro what the heck
whoa why are all my friends dead
[Music]
are there bad boys in here
[Music]
ignore ignore that ignore
foreign
you didn't see or hear anything
[Music]
excellent
let's go Garrett sounds good
I think I can sum it up not a clickbait
comment Souls like I'll have similar
elements they are all roguelikes with
deep cryptic narratives that all focus
on disrupting flow of life and death
yes
I think it's what I'm saying is I think
it's totally fine to call sakiro a Souls
game
based on the elements of what you're
saying it's those like just calling it
Souls I think it's fine everyone
understands it everyone knows what the
[ __ ] it means it trying to like say like
well it's not technically like you're
you're that annoying kid that nobody
likes when you're like that
stop
see what I'm saying
at least to me you're annoying it you
know I don't know
sorry
did I rest I'm gonna do the rest rest
okay
lady butter I struggle with lady
butterfly big time so this if I beat her
first try that'll be um
I'd be surprised
does he have like a pig
got a weird body on this one
who do I have snap seeds
oh I think he gives me some
that will that will be helpful
you gave me one
just one
thanks man
I should have ichimanji on because you
know
why not
a singular Snapseed
wait do I get to keep that Snapseed
like if I die and come back do I get it
again
ichimanchi
foreign
they get really out here giving me one
try huh
uh
girl you good
no kidding outlaw
James let's go
sashina
this fight's all about deflecting
I don't know
badass
good sorry couldn't have been worse
actually
so God my game's freezing
[Music]
[ __ ]
oh God I don't know what I'm doing
[Music]
it's not freezing
foreign
it keeps freezing
oh you gotta jump that one
would I just do to her
weird
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Bad start
much better
much better there obviously
okay I got my Snapseed ready
look at her she's up there
being a hoe
[Music]
snap
that doesn't even take all of them out
[ __ ] worthless dude
okay we just gotta Outlast
[Music]
I had to use it in the middle
um
[Music]
no no no no
New York
well I forgot about the
the little fairies that come and kill me
and
I just used a pellet for no reason I'm
I'm over it I'm over it rest again
damn it
all right no more snap
shoot your [ __ ] man
no more snapseeds
let's try that again
yeah they're butterflies or something I
don't know you know like lady butterfly
is that what you're saying
[Music]
where you going grandma
jump you [ __ ]
[Music]
nope
let me get it thank you
foreign
[Music]
like purposely fake it
was kind of cool
[Music]
I don't know why I struggle with that uh
[Music]
that attack
s
[Music]
[Music]
I got no more snaps
[Music]
can I hit her down
come on Grandma snap it
thank you
oh wait not again
not again not again not again
I was about to make the exact same
mistake
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
get out of here
no
[Music]
you're not allowed to do that twice
[Music]
it's not allowed can I kill him like
this
[Music]
foreign
hiding
now not fair I disagree with that
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
get out of your grandma
coming
Oh Come two tries
two tries
I remember this was one of the first
games I streamed on Twitch or not one of
the first
but I stream this game on Twitch back in
2019 when it came out
I kid you not I was on lady butterfly
for six hours
and now we can beat her in two tries
that's pretty cool
right the warm-up doesn't count so one
try technically
died anyway
Pro Gamer confirmed
true
it's true
uh excuse me
you stabbed you who do you think
that was a big sword
foreign
boss that took you the longest to beat
I kid you not it was Frida
she took me days first time I fought her
literally days of attempts
couldn't do it
eventually I got it
I remember I didn't touch the game for a
week after lady Frida and then I went
back and did the rest
are you
today
I don't really use those super often
rich so we'll go back if we need it
okay I'll see you later man
foreign
doesn't make sense how did Kuro get back
to sakiro
sekiro after
knowing Al was watching everything in
the background
huh
I'm confused at what you're saying
45 attempts over two to three days I
mean for Melania it took me like it took
me like five six hours to beat Melania
long time but it wasn't like days in
between
like we play we fought orphan for the
first time last week in bloodborne and
that took us what four hours I think
so
just depends just for me lady Frida was
the hardest I don't know why
this was
foreign
I am pretty cool
you could say no
goodbye
okay
let's go fight
that [ __ ] not a [ __ ] the uh
who am I thinking of inichiro I think is
that his name I think it's kenichiro
Al can't harm Kuro
I would think that's like in the lore he
doesn't want
to he's trying to use him for his blood
which is why owl wouldn't just kill him
he wants to use him
because Kuro has the Divine blood
ashina Castle
metal helsinger no I don't what's that
it's a good game
I've not I haven't even heard of it
we want to do these no
no no shoot
ER
awesome
what
I'm gonna go straight to kenichiro
if my [ __ ] grapple would ever work
dude
uh I was just gonna do the main ending
but we can do whatever you guys want
get your
Woos ready
all right this ain't good
okay that just kills me oh you're over
there I see
stay over there sir
all right everyone you got your
s ready to go
sir [ __ ] you
I'm coming to get you
not yet hold the
shh oh okay
okay
yes
excellent
somehow got through that
all right we have to go over here
now
yeah I tried to Parry the woo and
yeah he didn't get to me
got another gourd seed
my game's freezing a lot I don't know
what's up with that
okay
I don't know about you guys I always
Sprint through this area
[Music]
hey Subzero am I late
um I mean I started three hours ago so
that depends on your definition of late
[Music]
oh come on
why can't I move
can I please get that
I would really appreciate it
[Music]
ow sir
[Music]
you guys see why I skipped this area
okay
[Music]
holy [ __ ] buddy
foreign
[Music]
relentless
thank you
dude I don't remember this being so hard
and always just let me grab it before
[Music]
this make him stop looking for me
[Music]
I'm over it
[Music]
damn it imagine I get that first try
though
I hate the sky
I hate him
Gail's the most brilliantly designed
boss ever
yeah Gail Gail's definitely one of the
best fights in Dark Souls for sure
best spots best fights in the series
were definitely
[Music]
your stream is one of the top results
when I search Elder drink on YouTube
uh do you subscribe to me
so that's probably why
[Music]
[ __ ] sweet
I'm only ready for the other stuff man
thank you
[Music]
nice
got him
hanging scroll
yo
let's calm the music down please I think
we're good
damn
music goes so hard in this game
not my work computer but my personal
account does oh okay
well
I guess that's a good thing Dee I have
no idea
get the [ __ ] out of here you goddamn
Bots
I got it
I killed the bot
mikuyo foreign
like that everyone's Barefoot most of
the time
or sandals
that's how I am
suringa Vegas
there I am
um
[Music]
[Music]
only take a moment right
first time through
three hours
foreign
[Music]
not fair
[ __ ]
[Music]
very good start
[Music]
nice
[Music]
[ __ ] you
how do I jump on his head
foreign
enough fair enough
sometimes he jumps and sometimes he
doesn't
[Music]
I just gotta jump twice
I'm doing that
the [ __ ]
I swear I'm doing it
dude you almost like can't heal in this
fight
[Music]
oh we did the same thing you see that
that was sick
[Music]
okay
okay I work that time
foreign
[Music]
broke the posture right away
foreign
first try to stage three that's pretty
good
I guess
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
nice try buddy
[Music]
foreign
not like this
that's my fault
dude I literally think
I threw
we get to do it again
yeah the reversal for lightning is so
cool
but uh
yeah he kind of messed me up there no
cap
I had it I got hit by something I did
not think I'd get hit by and then it was
like over from there
unfortunate let's go again
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
very nice
movie
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
nice
nice
[Music]
[Music]
okay way better
that's a good point
[Music]
foreign
oh my God that fight was almost perfect
it was so good
owned
owned
God the the combat in this game when
you're getting it right when you're in
that zone when you're in the flow is
like you can't beat it it's it's so good
it feels amazing
feels so good when you get in that
rhythm
that is kind of required in this game
obviously feels awesome
ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding
it's like playing Guitar Hero or
something
at first I was like haven't you two met
before but then he didn't know if she
was with him I was like oh that's why he
attacks or draws a sword almost
the combat feels like a dance just like
sword fighting is it's like a dance
makes sense
this game won game of the year right in
2019 I'm pretty sure it did
I don't have shoes on either
it did that's what I thought
I gotta pee again
I can play for like another 45 minutes
oh yeah the guy returns he's
he's got the Divine blood he's like us
he can't really well he can die you just
have to do in a very specific way
okay friends
I will give you a gorgeous view
uh
uh actually it's kind of snowy right now
no gorgeous view
um
I will show you guys Emma
while I go pee
BRB
we back
yep I took a [ __ ] that fast bro I did
foreign
you leave the cam on your feet
because I couldn't
how do you kill those purple skull
[ __ ] The Headless
uh you need Divine confetti to fight
them
I believe
Divine confetti helps with the Headless
they're also just really hard
foreign
there's a lot of talking in this I think
I'm just gonna skip all of it because
it's really not that important
uh okay we got enhanced attack power
excellent
we can
enhance our physical attributes
excellent
we can acquire some skills
actually some skills you know how I
would be
um reduces the amount of damage to
posture when attacked by a sword we
definitely want that
um after killing an enemy one must
exhale recovers posture upon executing a
successful death blow we like that as
well that is big pogger Walker smile
um
recovers Vitality upon performing a
death blow we definitely want that so
I'm just gonna go ahead and get this and
never use it
and then mid-air deflections are nice
but we want to get to here
that's the next thing we want
yeah breath of life is really good we
want that for sure
I'm gonna skip all this guys it's a it's
a ton of talking it has to do with the
blood and [ __ ]
oh wait
can we even decide here
I've played the game before Kudo like
when the game came out
what are you talking about Brian
is this the DLC
there is actually
not DLC engine in uh sakiro
I just wanna one of the things I'm
saying
that uh they might not do DLC for Elden
ring I'm just throwing that out there
guys this game won game of the year and
they didn't make DLC for it probably
because they were working on Elden ring
but
I'm just I'm just throwing that out
there as a potential it's there
but they haven't done it but it's
probably because they were working on
Eldon ring while making this game
so that's one of my theories Ryan is
that
Elden ring might not have DLC
it's possible
they added a Boss Rush
I'm not calling that DLC bro I'm just
not
they did add some stuff
DLC was already announced
no it wasn't that was fake
you forehead
not real
ity
it's not already announced Julie
I don't know how many people still think
that that was like actual factuals
real stuff
interesting
the fake leak
s
there foreign
you're saying if I hide behind a wall I
can listen to Kuro talk to Emma or
something
I think there will be DLC too I'm just
saying there's a chance that there won't
be and they're making another game
he'll talk to himself so if I go like
right here
when did you
lose your path
Lord ganichiro
oh so he's sad about it
that's cool I haven't seen that before
he's sad about kenichiro
losing his way
are you saying you've seen someone you
watch that mortality watch Towers okay
let's go find our boy
secret boss huh
interesting
this man wants some sake let's go
give drink
s
[Music]
[Music]
right he's just telling us about the
Mortal blade is the way to kill someone
who has the Divine blood
[Music]
where can it be found Temple
[Music]
but if you draw the Mortal blade you die
but we can die twice which means we can
hold it
Severance
it severs Immortal ties
also
if you hesitate you lose in battle
don't hesitate
hesitate and you die
is that it
no you Google
hesitate and you die boys
hesitation is defeat
[Music]
foreign
behind a wall again will Caro say
something different
besides sneezing
oh same thing
is the key to severing immortality
mortal blade telling us what it is
we need to find a flower
about the flower
it is said that
relatives of Tom away
once gathered The Fountainhead fragrance
and arrived at a palace you may find a
key
you may find a key where the Waters of
Rejuvenation converge in a deep pool a
white and deeply frigate flower which I
believe is the flower behind
the ape correct
looking for information
[Music]
gotta go to the age
in the deep valley
Sunken Valley
beyond the woods to the rear of the
castle
foreign
Sakura drops lit
give soccer a droplet
giving it to me
how different are the bosses for each
ending
um
you can look them up
the sure ending is where we fight Emma
and Isha
he's like a different ishin
wa
[Music]
Dora marked with the outline of a person
the Shinobi shortcuts
let's go do that
talk to Emma first actually
you already missed your ending
um is that true
I don't think so
that's not true
Lord you thank me you can eat you bro
foreign
we've decided to sever the ties of
immortality
okay sorry you were talking amongst
yourselves
gourd seed
excellent I can give her a drink
oh my God
I'll have some delicious
we're getting her drunk
who trained you to fight with a blade
I'm a doctor Lord ishin he's been
trained by Lordi
I do not believe your skill counts as a
mere passing interest
well not to kill people hi
I don't have the slightest desire to
kill anyone
he wants to kill a demon if one were up
here
like shura right yeah
okay
let's go I think we go this way and we
go out like
we fall down into the water right to go
to
the temple
we can do something like that no this is
the front
we want to go
the other way
yeet
we want to go
this way
[Music]
oh they saw me no more eavesdropping
up
hey oh my bad
we got a big boy here huh
foreign
[Music]
he literally shot me
and then I got stabbed at the exact same
time
that is pain
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] you
[Music]
no
[Music]
there we go
Point sakiro Elden ring and dsc1 on
keyboard and mouse only switch
controller because damn Dark Souls 3
didn't want to show keyboard layouts
yeah I would say most people play on
controller with these games for sure but
I mean you can it can be done
monkey
run
monkey monkey monkey monkey monkey
[Music]
hey our boys here
sir
[Music]
[Music]
yeah I play on controller
it's definitely designed with controller
in mind
I have mastered some techniques
I did too
cute
what was he referring to like is there
something I need to do for him to be
like yo what up bro
because I I did too get a skill
of the ashina Arts I have the ichimanji
in all of these
what a forehead
oh I have to get the final technique
I mean
I have to go all the way to the end damn
bruh damn okay
all right how do we get to the monkey
the monkey
I think we go this way right
audit
hmm
did I remember getting literally lost
around here
foreign
to time
can I go back up okay
oh God not these guys man
[Music]
I have to go through the valley first
right
where these guys are
foreign
no we have not killed the snake where
can I kill the snake
I would like to do that actually because
I am not a fan of snakes
I don't know about you guys snakes scare
me
and I don't want them around
there's a reason I've only made one
Reichard video
it's because I don't like I don't like
anything about him man
he scares the [ __ ] out of me I hate
snakes
they are terrifying to me
it's a bit of a track we'll get there
when we get there a [ __ ] prayer bead
just sitting on the ground
this guy's out here playing Call of Duty
how hard is the snake
you literally just stab him in the head
I think if I remember right
I think they go I have to
get the I have to unlock diving
this is the dead end yeah I'm just here
come on
now I'm pretty sure we stab him in the
top of the face
feel as though Elden ring was good and
bad the good outweighs the bad and
aren't too far apart
guys there's problems with everything
you know what I'm saying
but would you all agree that the
honeymoon phase that we likely all had
with Elden ring is kind of worn off a
little bit
you can do it once you get Ninjutsu I
think I have Ninjutsu I do have ninjutsu
blood smoke
blood Smoke's pretty cool
the honeymoon phase is definitely worn
off with Elven ring and now we can see
all of the
kind of annoyances with it a bit there
definitely are
that's right I need to get the puppet
one so the monk yeah I remember that the
monkey right
fake mind control of the monkey
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
you go down here no okay so I do have to
go through this area
oh boy
I agree Archies
[Music]
something can be incredible and can have
issues
there nothing is perfect
perfect is not achievable it's not a
real thing you can't do it
I don't even think it's fair to even try
to be you know have a perfect game have
a perfect whatever it's not a thing and
I think a lot of people do think it's a
thing for some reason
that games and and literally anything
can be perfect
it's not a thing
sorry to burst your bubble on that one
tell if you're
oh God here we go
[Music]
Bonk
oh God this area bro
perfect is objective
I agree
if Alden ring doesn't run game of the
year I'm gonna be pissed
as of right now it should be game of the
year
also we are definitely playing
bloodborne on stream by the way
not bloodborne we already did uh God of
War is what I meant to say we're
definitely gonna play the new God of War
on stream
gorilla
there hasn't been any awards yet
Archie's it's won some game of the year
but we're talking about the main one
but it hasn't started yet
pretty sure Ragnarok will be the only
one to challenge it at least so far
oh yeah Trey I gotta get off in about 20
minutes so we're gonna see how far we
can get here but yeah
I'm still on
oh these [ __ ] guys
[Music]
I hate fighting these things
foreign
just decided to shoot faster that time I
see
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
that feels good
I got the flow
[Music]
State achieved
[Music]
what is this main Game of the Year award
you're talking about it's the one with
the
what's it called
with the guy named Jeff
that's the main one
[Music]
I think it's just called The Game Awards
okay dude
no I don't use the umbrella
after Lisa don't shoot me we need you to
cut it out okay
I remember at some point being able to
just run through that area and be
totally fine and now now they're
tracking me
consistently
[Music]
yeah having long hair means I have a
mullet that's right
it's the only conceivable hairstyle with
long hair on a guy right
what the [ __ ]
he just jumped off
that was weird
I did not press the jump button for him
to do that
[Music]
foreign
it's not a mullet guys it's just a long
hair it purls in the back what mullet
have you ever seen curls
in the back
[Applause]
[Music]
apparently I don't know what a skull it
is
[Music]
there's something down here
maybe not
keep going
oh this [ __ ] guy
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
better know how to deflect if you're
gonna fight that guy though
I got the fan
rap
I even open this yet no
have to go a different direction if I
want to do that right
yellow gun power
yeah I can't even go this way yet
I have to go the other way
so we will come back
and we can
gravel
to
here
holy [ __ ] lucky you're spamming bro
that boss taught me proper deflection
exactly exactly dude
[Music]
come on
got the Gatehouse key
yeah you should probably not you know
you should practice not doing that habit
here
are you guys ready for the skip
boom
hey what up man
oh
my God
she made
squishy
Una
kanashina
boy
underwater
this guy's out of his mind bro
ownership
well sure dude
big dude
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Jack
ET
[Music]
I have not
sure
hmm
KFC or Popeyes
Popeyes is better
sorry
all right
there's someone I can fight over here
get rid of these [ __ ]
bumped
okay
[Music]
come on
sum up
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
no okay there we go
another prayer bead
we like that this is where we started
right yeah
this is where we started the game by the
way
we can go up here because we have a
grappling hook
whoops
I want the item please give me the item
please
abandoned dungeon
[Music]
oh yeah
yep
oof
anybody else just not [ __ ] with these
guys in any way shape or form until you
have like the proper stuff
foreign
how'd you get down here
oh God
he's being called To You by something
yeah Sakura was actually pretty short
overall it's pretty short
alone
foreign recycling areas where does they
recycle areas
[Music]
cousin
castles invaded twice
I mean it all takes place here you know
it makes sense
it is a pretty small map
[Music]
s
this guy's nuts
definitely a little bit cuckoo
[Music]
hello
[Music]
thank you Blitz we're getting there slow
and steady
we grow every day
little by little now though
I remember I mean when elder ring was
really popping off like back in April
and I'd say mostly April and May
I think I was getting like
a thousand Subs a day it was freaking
crazy now we're getting like
a hundred to 200 a day so
scaled down very much but we grow every
day which is good
you know
it would be bad if we weren't growing
but we are little by little now
but the the interest in Elden ring is
I believe in an all-time low now
uh because everyone beat the game and
they're kind of over it you know
okay guys
I have to stop here
I can only stream till one today and
that's in about five minutes so I'm
gonna cut it here
I haven't eaten anything today too so I
want to go eat
um
appreciate y'all being here I had a lot
of fun
we're gonna keep going tomorrow I'll be
streaming all weekend I'm streaming
today
Saturday Sunday and Monday
which I think will be my normal schedule
from now on I was really trying to
figure out like what days I want to
stream on what days I want to work on
videos on because I do want to start
getting to the flow of making videos
again
um I haven't really had that much
interest in doing so lately but I'm
gonna kinda
you know kick myself in the butt and
just like get going with it because you
know I like making videos and I just
need to like get into it again you know
um
so If You're Expecting streams they'll
be around nine in the morning CST
depending on where you are just look up
CST you can
figure out what time that is for you but
nine in the morning till about now
about 1pm four hour streams each time
Friday Saturday Sunday and Monday and
then I can work on videos through the
rest of the week so
that's it appreciate every single one of
you thank you for the support
great stream as always streams have
always been super fun on here I'm having
a great time with it so
thank you all very much we will continue
tomorrow same time
but peace out have a great rest of your
day
and I'll see you soon
these dudes